[Music]
all right everybody today on the show we
dedicated a full hour to servers in the
food industry and now it is time to
celebrate you
so we asked y'all to send in um just
some of your most memorable
moments and also everything's falling
apart but it's fine
but maybe like by the end of this
everything just falls apart into that
behind the scenes
so one time i was waiting tables in san
antonio texas
and i went to introduce myself to my new
four top
i said hi welcome to blah blah blah my
name is son
i got stung by a hornet
[Laughter]
that's actually awesome my name is
[Music]
i was working the counter at steak and
shake back in 1990
we had a guest come in and order a steak
burger rare
like as in moo his exact words
what they said rare as in moot like they
like they just want it alive and
bleeding and
whoa gnarly that's not my thing
that's not my thing i like things cooked
[Music]
i was working as a waitress and a pizza
place and it was a blizzard out there
was a blizzard outside
some guy called in and asked if we gave
out free pizza to streakers
i said no about 20 minutes later i see a
cab
pull up and this guy comes running in
the door with nothing on but his tennis
shoes
he runs around i'm pretty sure this is
legal um he runs around the restaurant
then runs back out the door
i am standing at the waitress station in
the middle of the dining room in shock
i did try to tip him oh trip him on the
way out though
i'm pretty sure that's illegal yeah
like are there children out they don't
want to see your junk man
[Music]
i once had a guest order a burger but
wanted it completely deconstructed
that's right bun burger toppings
including the condiments
all on one plate but not stacked on top
of each other
the man's table probably collected a
dozen small plates
and ramekins before all was said and
done
because of course he got fries too and
needed all the dipping sauces for those
don't we all have a friend like this
when they order in restaurants and
you're like
these people are going to spit in my
food this server is definitely going to
spit my food or drink because they hate
our table because of this one person
[Music]
okay i was a servant in applebee's and
the city i worked in was in the
southwest
so in the summer we would run our air
conditioner on full blast
one day a gentleman i was serving asked
if i would turn the temperature up to
make it less cold
i told him i would talk to management
and see what we could do minutes later i
look over the table and this man had
unfolded all the paper napkins at the
table and had
draped them on his upper body to create
some sort of
makeshift blanket to keep himself warm
uh dramatic
he was sitting there looking stone-faced
wearing these
damn napkins i thought okay you're cold
i get it
like what
okay i used to have a regular that would
come in and order a blt except when i
would bring it to the table he would ask
me
to take the bacon off with my bare hands
in front of him
okay this got weird and kinky i don't
know it got a little weird
then he would hand me a 20 for a five
dollar sandwich
hey 20 bucks is 20 bucks oh my god
that is so weird that guy wants to wear
someone's skin you know
he's got someone trapped in his basement
you want me to hand
pick your bacon off your sandwich okay
um i was a cashier at a hospital
cafeteria
a man tried to steal sausage patties by
putting sausage patties are better than
links let's just agree
okay true not exactly a man tried to
steal sausage patties
by putting them in his coffee the kicker
was the jelly containers he put
in his coffee to try and hold
them down what kind of hospital were you
working at
[Music]
one time i was carrying a large plastic
gallon of french dressing
i was walking past the counter that had
several men sitting drinking coffee and
talking
i didn't realize someone had just mopped
the floor i slid
dropped the jar on the floor it landed
on its bottom and the lid flew
oh and the lid blew up french dressing
shot up in the air
in the air really high but then it came
down on me and all the men
not one man was mad they were all
worried about me
some jumped the counter to help me we
were all covered in french dressing of
course i was covered the most
the men came back many more times after
that
okay customer does the ist have caffeine
in it
me yes it does customer
[Music]
can you take it out oh my god i wish me
said
no you dummy
like decaf tea or caffeinated tea
that's not how you make decaf tea thank
you all so much for sharing your stories
i want to give a huge shout out to
everyone working in the food
industry you service you all deserve the
best it's a hard job
we see you we appreciate you and we
thank you please stay
safe out there and i just hope you have
a blessed day
and if not maybe tomorrow will be better
[Music]
you